all right we've got jason here with us
jason what's going on man
hey pop can you hear me hi ken how are
you
good hey joe hey john
jason how are you we're super excited
man we got a lot to go through you ready
yeah i'm ready if you're ready all right
let's start first with i want to kind of
set the scene before we start talking
about some of the nuances of bitcoin
proof of work national defense etc uh
obviously this stuff's really hard to
talk about it's complex there's all
sorts of nomenclature that is very
specific
uh people interpret different terms
different uh ideas differently help us
understand just like how you think about
talking about this stuff and the
language that's used uh as we kind of go
into the conversation
yeah
so this is where my background comes in
really handy
so i'm an astronautical engineer in the
space force
and
my and also a national defense fellow at
mit so my job is quite literally to
understand the emerging technologies out
there and how they could affect national
security in the future and in previous
jobs for example when i worked at the
national air and space intelligence
center
my job would be to basically reverse
engineer far in electronic warfare
systems explain their significance to
diverse audiences who who don't have
backgrounds in electronic warfare to
include
the potus daily intel brief so i know a
thing or two about explaining the
strategic implications of emerging
technology to policy makers and so when
i came to mit that was my goal from the
very beginning we were as a national
defense fellow i'm required to
understand or write about the strategic
implications of emerging technology and
i chose bitcoin specifically for reasons
that we'll talk about during this
podcast but
the bottom line there is
when it comes to explaining any
technology even the easiest and most
simple technology it's actually
really really awkward
and really difficult to do and i have i
thought it would be fun to
to prove this to prove how awkward it is
to explain how technology works by
basically quizzing you if you let me i
mean i don't think i could say no i
didn't know we were going to do this but
uh let's try
okay this box is me getting absolutely
demolished i'm going to call it in
advance of an mit national defense
fellow
and a active space force uh
uh
now i'm interested in seeing what jason
pulls up here
go ahead so
so all the brothers should participate
in this okay so here's their show they
go smart
so i just went around my house and
picked up some technology and i want you
to explain to me the significance of
this technology so here's technology
number one
what what is that sugar
this is uh
it's cinnamon and sugar inside all right
uh
basically it makes the food taste well
uh tastes good and and also preserves
the food for long periods of time
so you're describing what the technology
does explain to me what this technology
is uh it is a cylinder with a hole with
a cap that has holes that gradually let
the substance through
okay so that's that's better that's
better you're talking about the form of
this technology
it's a clear cylinder it's a clear
container of some kind with holes in the
top and what's the purpose of the holes
to let the substance flow through
when i turn it upside down it'll come
out
and it'll make a mess but you'll notice
that when it comes out it it's a gradual
flow right by constraining the flow when
i turn this thing upside down it comes
out at a smooth predictable pace so
what's the value of this technology in
our life
well it depends on what the economic
output is that you get from using it
yeah it it has different value
for two
it has different value to depending on
how you use it for if i fill this with
salt it has different value if i fill
this with pepper it's got different
value if i fill it with cinnamon and
sugar
the value that this brings to my life is
it makes a nice even flow of
cinnamon and sugar on my toast
but but if you didn't have
history to tell you this and and this
was the first time you'd ever seen this
technology it would have been harder
so that was test number one i'm gonna
test you again
fantastic
same technology same form now explain
this to me
oh that's time
what are you talking about what what is
this technology describe what it is
symmetrical cylinders that allow
another substance to flow through at an
even rate
okay so what's the difference
one
number of holes is the difference uh
shape is the difference
made out of the same material for the
most part
yeah
so instead of a bunch of holes it's got
a single hole
and that hole is created by basically
pinching
the container and so when i spill this
upside down it falls on the floor or on
my toast because i want it to
when i turn this upside down
that flow of particle on the inside is
captured
okay so obviously the value that this
brings to our life
versus this is that we don't lose what's
in here right that must be the value
because that's the difference correct
but is that actually the value that it
brings to our lives no
what is the value that it brings to our
life well how would you know
it's how they're used
okay
keep going
i i don't know man i got it c's and d's
in school it's awkward
so so these are basic technologies and
it's awkward already awkward correct
it's difficult it's difficult to
unpack not just in the way that we talk
about in everyday life but actually to
in some way uh view them both from an
engineering standpoint of the actual
technology form factor but also in the
application of that engineering
by taking this
by putting one hole and capturing it on
the other side
we the value that this brings in to our
lives transcends the parts it's more
than the sum of its parts
we create this magical property where we
can now
partition time itself we can transform
sand into time itself and track the
passage of time
time to come and time passed
that is amazing that is miraculous by
just this simple thing
but if you go around and you talk about
what technology is
literally what technology is
and not the emergent property of that
technology the value it brings to our
lives you will draw very different
conclusions about what this technology
is useful for
would you agree i would definitely agree
and so now take this problem
but
take it away and make it software so
it's invisible
now you have to describe how software
works what its form what its emergent
properties are and that gets really
freaking hard really fast correct
right it becomes triple awkward because
technically the function of all software
is identical
it it is simply to sell it to tell a
discrete state machine
what state to be in zero or one that's
what all software does it
right that's that's exactly right it's
purpose okay and technically the the
form so not only
the form
uh
is the same also so the form of
technology is just a set of instructions
to tell a state machine what to do
so that gets super confusing
right and and by the way everything
everything that we use to describe
software to include programming language
to include this idea of while loops and
for loops and routines and subroutines
and clouds right or containers and all
the things that we use
are just abstractions they're just
metaphors because the literal form of
software is just instructions that tell
a discrete state machine what to do
so we have to formulate these
abstractions which may not be accurate
the cloud is not really a cloud
just someone else's computer
it's just how we deal with that
complexity okay so there's two more
technologies
that i want to quiz you on are you ready
uh yeah i guess
because we're gonna we're gonna take the
awkward game up a notch okay because
we're gonna get into a politically
sensitive
technology fantastic there's not a
controversy we didn't like on this show
go ahead okay
explain to me what this does
oh that that's a killing machine
okay
that's one way to look at it right now
so well it's a sharp blade that has uh a
multitude of uh sharp blade with a what
is that a rubber handle or something
yeah hard plastic hard plastic yeah so
do i use this to chop up my salad
probably should i use it right what do i
use this for
i mean islands
so if i'm i used to live in vandenberg
if i'm taking a hike in the mountains of
vandenberg
you want this thing on your side because
you're probably going to see a mountain
lion while you're out there
so
okay so so first of all let's describe
what this technology is
it's a hunk of metal
yep and if you apply energy to it
it converts energy
into
what we'll call property defense correct
so this is a hunk of metal
i apply some energy to it with my hand
and i have a way to
physically stop attackers whether it be
a mountain lion or whether it be
someone else a person right would you
agree that's an empirically accurate way
of describing this technology i would
okay i'm also impressed that you're
gonna fight a mountain lion with a knife
but i probably
yeah maybe it's just like really small
or something
um i'm in the space force i'm not i'm
not in the army
let's just put it that way
so
so uh
but the point is
this technology has a form
the form is a hunk of metal i apply some
energy to it i'm able to not only
physically stop attackers but also deter
them i flash this thing and maybe
someone will back off because they know
i'm in i'm threatening harm to them or i
i'm i'm showing that it will be
cost prohibitive to try to attack me you
might be able to succeed the mountain
lion might be able to get me but not
without a couple cuts along the way
correct
okay
explain to me
what this technology is
geez that is a uh uh a piece of metal
that has a lot of energy applied to it
very rapidly and seems to be unstoppable
in many cases
okay
would you agree this is a hunk of metal
that converts energy into property
defense yes
very very accurate for those who are
just listening by the way he's holding
up a gun
okay
so i put some energy into this thing
energy is contained not in my arm but
contained in this capsule yep right i
put some energy into this thing and i
can stab people with the with the bullet
at the front of it right
so it's
it's basically a knife at uh arms length
away
yeah so so now in this awkward
conversation of trying to explain how
technology works even when we can see it
even when it's clear even when we have
intuitive understanding because this
technology
has it is older than all of us so we we
were born and raised understanding what
this technology is for it's still hard
to describe correct because
these have the same
function
but they have completely different form
okay so is the knife the same as the gun
in form no but in the function of
defensive property rights it is exactly
so now i've shown you two examples mit
needs to give me a freaking degree
[Laughter]
right similar form
very different function would you agree
yes
okay
similar function very different form
would you agree yes the gun and the
knife are uh very similar functions but
different uh forms okay so when that
happens we give it another name let's
call this a weapon would you agree
they're both weapons yes
so we use the term weapon
to show that these things have similar
function
all be it different form now have you
ever heard the term don't bring this to
a this fight yep don't bring a knife to
a gunfight of course why why is that an
idiot why do people say that well the
gun may be a little bit more effective
at uh at the violent uh conflict than
the knife is
so let's use less politically sensitive
terms because when i say the word
violence on twitter that things don't go
well yeah
so
the which one is cheaper
which one is cheaper well depends on
what gun you buy but probably the knife
yeah this is about 100 times more
expensive than this one which one uses
more energy
uh the gun does
so it's more expensive and uses more
energy correct but it's more effective
right and so we can measure that
effectiveness through a term that we
call power we can literally measure the
watts that i can project by stabbing and
i realize how ridiculous i look right
now
i'm looking forward to the thumbnails on
this right
but but the point is this is way more
powerful than this correct which is why
you would never want to bring this
to a this fight right you never want to
bring a knife to a gunfight especially
if your adversary especially if someone
else is trying to who is trying to take
your property from you is carrying this
not a knife okay do you understand that
concept yes pretty straightforward
correct okay so
so some might call these i think it's
also an accurate way to call this a
denial of service countermeasure if
someone's trying to deny you service to
your property this is a counter measure
against it
would you agree yes
it's it's uh it's pretty hopefully only
used in a time where the denial of
service is very very very serious not
just uh john can't get mcnuggets at
mcdonald's
that's a great point so let's talk about
that
if you want to defend something you've
got three options
the first option the most energy
efficient the most cheap option to
defend your property is a concept we
call trust i will simply trust my
neighbor yep not right it's very energy
efficient to do that that's why
that's why trust is so important in in
society is if you have a
a high trust society you have a very
efficient society
but but there's something wrong with
trust there's a security flaw with trust
okay it's if if your
neighbor decides to break your trust you
have no way
to defend yourself
you have to find a way to project power
to defend yourself so your other two
options for defending your property are
you defend yourself
through
this technology
or you hire someone to defend you
through this technology correct does
that make sense yep either self defense
or you have police security whatever it
is exactly so this to me the reason why
i'm carrying this is for self-defense i
don't trust my neighbor
actually let's say this i do trust my
neighbor but this is how i verify right
yes right if if they break my trust to
your earlier point if they break my
trust this is how i verify that i still
have the means to defend myself
okay and it's not just a deterrence
mechanism i can literally physically
stop the attacker
i'll give him one courtesy shot over the
shoulder out of respect for their life
but the second one is not going over the
shoulder that's how you can guarantee
that you are in a zero trust position
you have zero trust and egalitarian
control over the property that you're
trying to defend
if you do not have this mechanism or
some other form of the same mechanism
you do not have zero trust control you
must find a hunk of metal that converts
energy
into defense correct
okay so
explain to me this is the final
final challenge are you ready yeah i
can't wait
okay the last time you did this you
pulled up a gun
oh this time you pulled up a uh a
digital defense mechanism which is a
bitcoin miner what is that a bit main
what is that an s19
i don't actually have a real one so i
had to print out the picture if anyone
wants to donate me a broken one you uh
for my for the school you're welcome to
do so but this technology
would you agree it's empirically valid
to say this technology is a hunk of
metal that converts energy to property
defense correct and probably does it
better than anything else in the world
okay so what do we call something that
has the same function but a different
form a weapon
i'll let you decide because
because when i
when i where you know
when the us national defense fellow goes
on air
with approval from the pentagon wearing
a uniform
to talk about bitcoin as a weapon system
it's extremely controversial to do that
i'm the first and only one that i know
of in any academic institution that is
treating bitcoin this way and i started
this well before
the national strategic military
implications of this technology showed
itself
on the world stage so clearly
so what are those hold on a second
this is important explain a little bit
about without getting into any one of
the uh current situations explain a
little bit as to how you think about uh
the national strategic defense
implications of bitcoin itself from like
a u.s perspective
well
this is where it comes down to this
conversation that we talked about
earlier
forum
software is tricky everything about
software
is hard it's invisible it's inherently
unintuitive
it's complex and confusing the size and
complexity of software scales to the
point where it can have infinite states
it can be it's like proteus it can take
any shape and it can run through like
every time a software runs a new
subroutine it's technically a wholly
different thing and you can have
thousands of subroutines in a single
piece of software
two people can have two different
abstractions and both be correct when
they describe the form and function of
software remember because these are just
abstractions
like software is only a set of
instructions that tells the discrete
state machine what to do so if you call
it gold but i call it a gun neither of
us are technically incorrect
more importantly
software can perform two functions at
once
okay so i get accused all the time of
being a hammer that looks like that
looks at bitcoin like it's a nail
and but but
the implication being well obviously
it's a monetary system so so the
screwdrivers are calling it a screw the
hammer is calling it a nail and people
don't understand that it can be both
things at once at the same time it is
both things at once well so
and so
so
where you remember your question was
about explaining the national strategic
implications of of bitcoin if you want
to understand it
don't look at the software look at the
hardware piece look at the thing that
everyone can see
okay this is how you describe the
national strategic implications of
bitcoin this is how you explain why
there is no replacement for bitcoin
people
both animals and people have been trying
to search for a substitute for this
humans have been doing it for 200 000
years
okay a way to defend their property more
effectively and by the way
the more energy you use the better your
defense is that's why you don't want to
take a knife to a gunfight energy is
good the power that you project the more
powerful a hunk of metal is that defends
your property
that protects it against denial's
service attacks is good and by the way
this allows you to actually
physically stop an attacker a denial
surface attacker it's not just a
deterrent it's like proof of stake this
is
ability to physically stop the attacker
so when you think of that or continue
so
my goal from the very beginning when
talking to policymakers
this is what's super frustrating
like i said i'm an astronautical
engineer in the space force and a u.s
national defense fellow at mit my job
what you pay me for
is to understand what this form will be
in the future and to posture this
country
to make sure that we have the most
powerful thing that we're not taking a
knife to a gunfight in the future
and so it's super frustrating when
people are talking to me about bitcoin
as if it's strictly a financial system
or strictly a monetary network
and acting like me that i'm not
qualified to be talking about this kind
of stuff
and it's also super frustrating to watch
a bunch of bankers
a bunch of business people a bunch of
finance people try to explain it because
then they get confused and they say oh
it's the digital version of this
and it's like you could have a phd in
economics and not understand the
socio-technical implications of this in
fact most of them don't
right
and then or they'll go well okay it's
digital energy you see we we take a
state machine and we digitally partition
it across a distributed ledger and the
people who are allowed to write on it
are the ones that find the knots and and
it's like miners searching for gold and
then we act surprised when a bunch of
people get freaking confused
about what you're doing or if you treat
it strictly as a property they're gonna
say why
what what makes bitcoin different what
makes bitcoin different than any other
type of digital property or digital
asset out there
so so
my goal is to just
take
this complex technology and boil it down
to something that anyone with no
background can understand can and then
make informed policy decisions on it
because if you treat it like a digital
version of this
your policy is going to look very
different than the digital version of
this because if you think it's just
digital property then you might say okay
well maybe it's a threat to usd hegemony
or this or that but if you realize that
this is the future of warfare what
happens when we just when we scale this
up
and it's not just me but now it's an
entire army of people what do we call
that
war
it's called war
okay
nations
live and die and are created and are
uncreated by their ability to understand
what form this will take and to be good
at that game in the future this is how
we defend everything that we value
people forget this and if a new
technology emerges if a new one of these
emerges
banning it is not an option
you can't ban your adversary from using
this right so when orphan the engineer
creates cannons he was the guy that
invented this
he figured out how to iron cast cylinder
fill one in with gunpowder fill another
end with a bullet he takes that
technology to constantinople and he
offers it offers to build it to
constantine constantine turns him down
says he can't afford it
you see the logical flaw there correct
because because orbin goes to a 19 year
old kid
the sultan sultan mahmed
and within a year
they're shooting down the walls of
constantinople the only you don't get
the option
right you have to buy it you if you
can't afford the cannon you buy orbin
you buy
von braun
okay so so these are
this technology has multiple shelling
points in history we use it for warfare
we devise mechanisms so that people pay
fees to other people to wield this
technology on their behalf correct
and that's precisely what we're doing
with this technology people who buy
bitcoin are subsidizing the development
of a new weapon system a new defense
industrial complex
and which one do you think is more
ethical
well definitely the bitcoin mining the
digital protection of property rights is
not only uh more ethical but it's also i
would argue much more uh effective in
achieving world peace because at the end
of the day
you end up actually knowing with almost
a
high degree of certainty or actually
with a high degree of certainty uh it is
impossible to penetrate uh versus uh as
we are watching right now in certain
areas of the world um some people are
confused as to you can use the uh uh the
gun uh and those types of weapons uh and
there's a question can we actually
overpower another region another army
another uh uh kind of uh citizenry and
when you look get into the digital world
uh you know that it can't be penetrated
in every way that you look at this
technology
what is the current conversation doesn't
make sense what is being discussed
at the national strategic level
is incongruent to what this technology
is and what it represents
obviously
the thing that projects more power the
defense technology that uses more energy
is a better defense system
obviously
the technology that can preserve
citizens private property rights
without spilling blood without the
unfortunate side effects of this is more
ethical
and obviously trying to ban this from
your country is only going to give your
adversary an advantage over you read
history read what happened when
whitehead goes invented the torpedo and
the royal navy the powerful navy turned
him down and said i'm not going to
invest in this technology because it
represents a threat to my naval hegemony
you don't get the option
not to part to turn where this
technology takes you all right so let me
ask you a couple of questions i want to
take this from uh conceptually this is a
really really big idea uh i don't think
anyone else has been able to one
identify and then to articulate this
idea the way that you've been able to do
it obviously your background
the current seat you sit in there's a
number of things that make you uniquely
positioned to talk about this
the first thing
is um weapons can be used for offense or
defense and last time we talked about
this idea that uh
certain situations are deemed as offense
or defense based on who you ask and so
some people may look at an offensive
move and say oh we're offensively going
in doing something and somebody says i'm
engaged in this conflict because i'm
defending against somebody else who is
doing something offensively so putting
aside offense versus defense
the united states looking at this
technology as a national strategic uh
initiative
buy miners
buy bitcoin
buy it all
like what is the way in which
they should be thinking about as a
policy maker there's a lot of uh
politicians who watch this show there's
a congressman literally coming on right
after you uh how should they be thinking
about
bitcoin in terms of what they can
actually go do the most important
question to ask yourself about how to
form your policy surrounding bitcoin is
not what you think about it it's what
other countries think about it put
yourself in the shoes of any country
that isn't nato that isn't china that
isn't russia they're being forced into a
position where they effectively have to
choose which nuclear power they should
subscribe to to allow those people to
denial a surface attacks them so if
russia and china re-price their exports
in digital one and get people to join
the digital wand network that doesn't
solve their denial of service
vulnerability they just choose a
different network a different sovereign
power to have the ability to denial
service attack them so every it's in
every country's best interest and el
salvador knows this
to
to make sure that you build an army of
this
to make sure that you have a hash force
so you can verify you can physically
prevent anyone from denying you access
to your sovereign wealth it's only a
matter of time until everyone figures
this out the only difference between
this and a war is how many countries
subscribe to this protocol and el
salvador is literally raising bonds for
people to fund the development of their
hash force they're already starting this
is
the game theory is has already begun and
so
knowing that the united states is number
one export is property defense as a
service knowing that this is the future
that could be the future of property
defense as a service you must realize
that this
is something that must be in your
inventory if you want to continue to be
a leader in property defense as a
service and if you're afraid if you're
going to sit there and think that
this technology is a risk to your
power projection hegemony then the
answer is you buy as much of it as
possible to make sure that it's
expensive for your adversary to join
this network and to make sure that when
they do
their capital does fly out or when they
do re-prosper themselves strategically
that we stand to benefit the most and so
these decisions like eu almost banning
proof of work because it uses too much
energy is literally then voting or not
whether to disarm themselves and posture
themselves for failure in the future
when other countries not your country
when other countries realize that the
best way to reduce the attack surface on
their sovereign wealth the best way to
have sovereignty period
is to verify
that no one can take your stuff
when you think about
bitcoin through this lens
bullets guns
missiles tanks name your weapon of
choice we can create more of them if it
may cost us money it may take time it
may require us to uh plan correctly et
cetera but if we want to go to war or we
want to defend ourselves from war
there's an unlimited number of bullets
that could be created given enough time
and money
bitcoin is not that way bitcoin only has
21 million it's the total supply how
does that change the analogy or how do
you think about a finite supply versus a
seemingly unlimited supply of some type
of weaponry
it means that if you move first you
stand to gain disproportionately over
the other ones it's the power law
and it's very significant because not
only does this reduce the amount of
bloodshed that's required to defend our
private property it doesn't reduce it
all with all the way i'm not saying that
this will replace war i'm saying it's a
supplement to war we're still going to
need the old we're still going to need
this stuff to defend the people who do
this
but but at the end of the day
if nations start converting
effectively subscribing to this
decentralized military all these
decentralized
property defense industrial complex
and and that and you're buying stock
you're effectively buying shares in this
industrial complex and those are purely
limited and that scarcity is enforced
through the same mechanism
then those who move first
over the next 10 years
and if this truly does become the new
property defense protocol that everyone
subscribes to
then you were posturing yourselves for
to become a superpower for the next
thousand years
the the asymmetric advantage of the
first mover it can cannot be understated
if it's true that this is going to be
the premier property defense as a
service protocol that replaces or
supplements this
when you think about the united states
one of the things that uh the u.s hangs
their hats on is obviously property
rights uh but also the second amendment
right for the individual to bear arms uh
how does that play into our evaluation
of this does that make us more likely to
go ahead and uh and understand this
perspective and act on it does that
actually put us in like an innovator's
dilemma type situation where we say oh
we already have property rights we
already have uh individual right to bear
arms and therefore we don't need you
know kind of more how do you think about
that
first of all for the innovator's dilemma
the problem is
you get disrupted the incumbents get
disrupted because they have the most
they have more to gain by
continuing on their path than by
pivoting and accepting the new
technology that's not true for bitcoin
the united states has the most to gain
from this so it's not an innovator's
dilemma it's just stupid not to do it
right like i studied competitive
strategy at mit like
you know so anyways um but i forgot what
the other question was oh the second
minute yeah second amendment so
so what what is the purpose to say in a
minute why did our forefathers put it in
there what was the intent
do you know to allow us to protect
ourselves from the overreach of anybody
whether it's our neighbors our
government or anybody else
our forefathers recognized
that you need to decentralize this
because if you don't
then you put yourself at a systemic
vulnerability where the people who wield
this can denial service attack the
citizens property so if only the state
is allowed to own this technology then
that's a security vulnerability for the
citizens it's a denial of service
security vulnerability for your property
so
to protect people against that they
allow us to hold this technology to help
decentralize this power projection so
that one
organization doesn't have 51 control
over
or at least to decentralize it somewhat
and so to that end
the right to mine at your house it
should in my opinion be protected under
the second amendment
and then how does the idea of software
as free speech play into this right
which is another kind of uh core tenet
of the uh american experience or
american democracy
there's plenty of
precedent where software has been uh
deemed free speech uh bitcoin as the
asset is obviously software
and so is there not only a protection
for things like minors under uh
potentially the second amendment but
also the first amendment protects uh
your right to exhibit uh or exercise
your free speech uh in using something
like this
so again pro software can be multiple
different things at the same time
it can be a weapon system it can also be
a language that should be protected
under free speech the problem you get
with this
is the government could say you still
have the right to free speech because
we're we're still letting you use
cryptocurrency it's just now you're
using our cbdc
so
the you have to look at the you have to
take a kind of adversarial viewpoint
again military officer i'm going to take
this viewpoint when you raise when you
when you have like michael saylor and
nick carter and all these awesome people
trying to fight off the esg foot by
pointing out how green
the energy uses it they're they're
effectively sisyphus they're just trying
to roll this ball uphill doomed because
because that that argument will never
defeat the
bitcoin uses too much energy argument
because you could say that bitcoin is
powered exclusively by the magic of
carbon captured unicorn farts and people
would still say it uses too much energy
people would still say it wastes too
much energy because they're viewing it
as
this and they say well there's a lot
more inefficient ways or a lot more
efficient ways to have that then they
view it at like this
and this kind of complains about the
energy consumption of the us military it
would be really stupid to say our
military is too powerful because that's
the point it would be really stupid to
say our military is
in it is um
expensive
because that's the point right the the
fact that you aren't being attacked it
makes it look expensive because you're
not using your military they're just
like training
and and practicing and then you'd be
like why are we paying them so much just
to stand around and train and attack but
the fact that no one is attacking you is
proof that all the energy that goes into
training all the money that goes into
building the military
is not wasted just like the energy that
goes into defending bitcoin against
denial service attack from people taking
advantage of the systemic vulnerability
of the longest chain is valid chain
consensus protocol
the fact that that isn't taken advantage
of is proof that the energy spent to
defend it from denial of service attack
isn't wasted
and so so step number one is if you try
to take the esg like it's more efficient
than it's your sisyphus you're rolling
the ball uphill just like if you try to
take the well it's protected under free
speech you're still sisyphus you're
rolling the ball uphill because you
aren't addressing the most important
part about bitcoin the thing that makes
it different than anything else all
these other technologies don't have this
and they'll say well we can still
protect your
right to free speech but use
altcoin use pompliano coin instead of
this we don't have that
but do you see the point like i can sit
here and i can make like give me like a
couple minutes and i'll make a
scarce
digital asset
yep it ain't gonna be
like
more powerful than that like it it
the value that makes bitcoin special is
not the digital asset
the value that makes bitcoin special is
the enormous defense industrial complex
that preserves zero trust and
egalitarian control over the digital
asset because no other digital asset has
that especially not proof of stake
assets
correct joe john what questions you guys
got jason if you were able to uh wave a
magic wand and when you talk to these
policymakers they understand it right as
a weapon instead of a monetary network
or system what would be like some of the
first things that you would implement if
you were in their position
if i were the king for the day that's
the question pretty much
um
i mean at the very least
like i would try to do whatever i can to
make people understand that the people
who are taking the risk the regulatory
risk
to stand up hash forces commercial hash
forces across this country are heroes
they are defending our private property
rights
and we should recognize them as such and
they're taking the risk despite all the
foot despite all the threats of eu
banning stuff or potus executive order
banning stuff they're they they
understand and appreciate the importance
of this technology and they're taking
that financial risk and so king for the
day at the very least is like stop
calling them stop villainizing them as
being like anti-esg or something like
that because
like esg also means
not just energy but like the value to
society
and the value to society of defending
your property with this is way more so
that would be step number one step
number two is
then we have to figure out okay now that
we recognize that this is very
that this could very well be the future
of power projection the future of
warfare so now we've got
you know we've got space force we got
air force we got navy we've got army
do
how do we make sure that that all
countries
have the maximum
property digital
asset property defense as well
and so
that's a tricky policy making question
but that's a much different policy
making question than what the current
conversation is because the current
conversation is a bunch of people who
don't understand software getting
confused right like we're not even close
to the point where we can actually have
an informed discussion on what the
proper
policy-making response to bitcoin is
until people understand it for what it
is and what makes it special compared to
everything else
and so i'll i'll explore a little bit
this in my thesis i'm i'm going to try
to like think about okay well if we live
in a future where all countries have
what are effectively hash forces what
might be will probably be mostly
commercial hash forces hopefully mostly
commercial house forces to kind of
protect against 51 tax but
in that future do we as a country need
to do anything to make sure we can still
secure
these people the old-fashioned way
so so to put it bluntly
in a future where
all the nations have hash forces
you might get enough the the if there's
ever a bad guy that would try to denial
a service attack bitcoin
by 51 attacking it their fear shouldn't
be oh well you know this people might
build this to physically stop me their
fear should be
nato will drop a
version of this
on top of their mining farm if they try
to attack this
uh network so these are the kinds of
questions that you have to start
actually thinking about and i know
saying this stuff is super
controversial but
we don't have time i thought i'd have
way more time and in just the six months
of starting to talk about this it's
already there's already a podus eo about
it and we already see it on the world
stage gotcha john what do you got for us
jason when you think about our
government and specifically what is the
gameplay here is it just accumulate as
much as possible is there an
infrastructure play and then if the us
or another country does this
what like what is the opposite what what
do every other country do
so if you ban bitcoin you give every
other country a head start you you
you see their development of this and
and you benefit them to your expense
okay so so every country is already
asking themselves should we exit this
denial of service network that it that
is very clearly a denial service that is
clear very clearly weaponized
and and so that represents a a big old
capital flight risk
now
and so it's important to remember
technology is part of the environment
the architects of the us financial
system don't get to control the
environment they can only control how
they posture themselves and their
systems in response to an environment so
if if bitcoin is part of the environment
if if it's a mountain
and you're and the policy makers are
flying an airplane at the very least
don't the play shouldn't be point your
airplane at the mountain and then blame
the mountain for
the the crash
at the very least
posture yourself to not hit the mountain
or if you hit the mountain you benefit
the most so what i mean here is imagine
that everyone in the current financial
system is in a burning theater we're
having our monetary savings being burned
or a little bit by the inflation or
we're now facing a risk where other
nations might exit the theater in mass
so that's a capital flight risk
how do you protect yourself against that
you buy the thing on the opposite end of
the exit door so that when that capital
flies out of the system you recapture
that purchasing power on the other side
so the united states at the very least
the only play that makes sense is you
buy as much bitcoin as possible because
if people exit
then at least you end up on the
positive end of of that outcome and
we're in this like perfect window of
opportunity because
because you've got the china's you've
got the russians you don't see this yet
they they they have the opportunity of a
lifetime to switch to bitcoin
and and force people
out of
the u.s financial system into their
system
but they are making digital wands so
they're creating all the same problems
over again and every third-party country
that isn't china russia hopefully will
be smart enough to recognize that
and so the question for these
third-party companies third-party
countries is not
which sovereign financial system
to pick the the question is
how much do i want to hedge with a
non-sovereign financial system
and so the united states better posture
themselves to benefit from that
and you do that by buying bitcoin so you
capture disproportionate value and
people flood into it but do you also
make sure that
your property that you own is an under
threat of denial of service attack if
you buy it which you which you insure
through
the same way you
defend your legacy physical property so
the play is buy bitcoin and especially
banks you should be buying up this as
much as you possibly can recognizing
that
that this is the future of your number
one export of property defense as a
service
when you think about this jason the last
thing i want to talk about is uh these
third-party countries uh so not the us
and kind of what we'll consider the
dominant western system and not china
and what is probably now considered the
dominant eastern system
how much intellectual humility uh so get
out of the technology get it on the
financial implications but the actual
clarity of thought intellectual humility
needed to say hey
i cannot control the global reserve
currency or or this monetary system this
financial asset uh and so the second
best option
is to
then be in a system where nobody
controls it and there's this sovereignty
that is returned to me um
is that just
literally you need your leadership if
you're in one of these countries to uh
have the intellectual humility and
clarity of thought or are there things
that people can do to
help their leadership understand what's
kind of playing out right now
i've got presidential advisors in my
class at mit and i've talked to them
about this and it isn't really
intellectual humility
because you can be intellectually humble
and view bitcoin as a financial system
and draw these same conclusions it's
rational to think maybe i should ban
this technology because it represents a
threat to my usd hegemony so you can be
intellectually humble and still draw the
wrong conclusion simply because you're
viewing the technology incorrectly
again the most intellectually humble
person that views bitcoin as a financial
system will draw a very different
conclusion than the intellectual person
who views bitcoin as a weapon system or
a property defense system
and and that's really what's key i'm
willing to stand up here and and take
all the flack for posturing
or for trying to describe bitcoin in
this light because i want to show people
that
that
this is a valid empirically valid
argument that we should be taking very
seriously and
and it it doesn't have to be this like
ridiculous thing where we view this as
like
you know the threat to
the united states
power
it's just it can be the continuation of
this thing and you just
and but you know again the screwdriver
is going to look at it like a screw so
the bankers are going to look like it
look at it as crew and even with
intellectual human humility they're
going to draw the wrong conclusion and
the the policy makers are going to look
at it like a screw and they're going to
draw policies that treat it like a screw
but software can be two different things
at once and maybe it is a nail and if
it's a nail holy crap
we don't have much time
yeah when uh when you think about this
if you had to answer in two sentences
you gave me a quiz i'm gonna give you a
quiz uh hopefully you you perform better
than i did uh if you had it in two
sentences every single person watching
this uh when they talk to uh whether
it's a congressman a senator a local
mayor a state governor uh or if they
even get to talk to somebody close to
the president at the national level what
are like the two sentences of what they
should say
um
keep your sword in front of you
your swords and your shields are fully
sufficient
and will prove very effective in battle
that's what i would say those are
some of the last recorded words
of emperor constantine the 13th
during the final siege of constantinople
and the end of the holy roman empire as
we know it
he was telling his soldiers
as the cannons were ringing out very
loudly and shooting down their walls
that their knives were fully sufficient
and will prove very effective at battle
and every single one of the officers he
was talking to
knew exactly what that technology
was because a year earlier
the engineer who built it
came to constantinople and met with them
and offered to build it for them
so
we cannot forget
how history plays out we cannot forget
that power is everything
if we want to defend what we hold value
valuable
and and so hopefully we can convince the
people who are in charge of policy
making this is the goal of
my research here
that they they they should at least take
this seriously because we don't want to
be
how the end of the holy roman empire
ended we want to be
the superpower of the future if this is
the power projection play cyber if this
is how you achieve
zero
trust egalitarian control over cyber
property we want to posture this country
to continue to be a superpower
i think that there's a lot of people who
are paying attention starting to
understand
some of the things you're saying so i
appreciate you continuing to uh to beat
the drum uh regardless of how much [ __ ]
you get just remember that uh the haters
they usually aren't uh punching down and
uh eventually they're just future fans
so keep up the the great work where can
we send people to uh to find you on the
internet where's the best place to send
them
by the way pomp you're a great example
of that because i watched you get
punched a lot over these last couple
years and then when they flip and do a
total 180 you treat them gracefully and
so you're kind of a role model for me
but anyways you can find me at jasonp
lowry
l-o-w-e-r-y on twitter i use twitter to
as part of my thesis methodology where i
develop core concepts and test those
concepts for empirical validity so like
all these things that i was telling you
hopefully i'll get a bunch of comments
and hopefully i'll get a bunch of people
that say you're wrong here or you're
wrong there and i'll read those and i'll
formulate the counter arguments or i'll
include those in my thesis when i when i
finally uh
write it all up i can't wait i'll be the
first one to read it and then we'll
bring you back and we'll do a whole
whole deep dive on the thesis and the
haters can watch from uh from the
sidelines so i appreciate you coming on
we'll definitely do this again in the
future
thanks pomp thanks joe john thanks jason
all righty